قد تدفع عشره ثمن البضاعه الاصليه ثم تندم
على سلعه لم تعمر طويلا هذا الحال السلع
المقلده حيث بلغ عدد اسواقها 73 سوقا حول
العالم حسب مكتب الممثل التجاري الامريكي
لكن الاسواق الالكترونيه لا يمكن حصرها
وبلغت قيمه السلع المقلده عالميا 1.82
تريليون دولار سنه 2020 وبحسب منظمه
التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه ومكتب الاتحاد
الاوروبي للملكيه الفكريه فان اجمالي
التجاره الدوليه للصلع المقلده تبلغ نسبته
3.3% من اجمالي التجاره الدوليه ارتداء
هذا المنتج يعرضك للمسائله القانونيه ودفع
غرامه ماليه قد تصل الى 300 الف دولار
وقضاء اعوام بالسجن قد تصل الى عشر سنوات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات